hallo
herzlich willkommen in meiner toten will
in einem video zuvor habe ich euch mal
das frontend rezept vorgestellt und
heute stelle ich euch das blüten
passende rezept vor
ich zeige euch jetzt mal kurz ist rezept
und wie man es herstellt und später das
sage ich noch ein paar worte dazu und
zum modell ihr passte und zum von land
und blödeln passt jetzt zeige ich
erstmal die zutaten an zutaten braucht
ihr ein ei größe l davon dass es hat
etwa 40 gramm dann fein 125 g besiegten
foto zu kommen und vier teelöffel cmc
das ist cappucci mittellose gibt es in
der apotheke oder in online-shops und
hat die nummer 466 und ist ein
konsistenz geber und verdickungsmittel
und dann braucht ihr noch eine prise
salz
zuerst gibt jetzt dass ihr euere
küchenmaschine da gibt jetzt noch die
prise salz meter zu und lasst dann die
küchenmaschine für etwa 10 bis 20
sekunden laufen so dass die eiweiß
struktur zerstört wird
bei niedrigster stufe gebe ich jetzt
nahm danach den puderzucker mit dazu
lasse aber etwa eine tasse übrig die
brauchen wir dann später noch
ich schalte jetzt gleich auf die höchste
stufe und das lasse ich dann etwa drei
bis vier minuten schlagen so dass eine
feste biomasse entsteht
die masse soll jetzt ungefähr so
aussehen dass spitzen entstehen beim
rausgehen des lov witz und da gibt jetzt
bei höchster stufe noch dieses 10 10
wieder zu und lasst es auch einrühren
und dann machen wir gleich weiter
und jetzt könnt ihr sehen dass die masse
ziemlich zäh geworden ist und genau so
nimmt es jetzt heraus kratzt hier auch
wieder die sachen raus und dann geht es
gleich weiter
den restlichen butter zurück geht ihr
dann auf die arbeitsfläche wie bei der
front masse auch schon da kratzt er
jetzt noch die eismasse drauf und damit
das alles verknetet
damit die macher jetzt nicht an den
händen klebt nehmt ihr wie beim fand
auch dieses paar - oft und bleibt damit
eure hände ein und dann den restlichen
puderzucker noch ihnen die blüten passte
ein kneten
die masse die sollte schön geschmeidig
sein und eigentlich nicht mehr an den
händen kleben teil ist dann ganz gern in
vier teile
und die könnt ihr dann zu cool und
formen und in kleine tüten einpacken
und da müsst ihr darauf achten dass wir
die tüten dann wieder luftdicht verpackt
die eingepackten passierte am besten
noch in eine plastikschüssel und
verschließt sich damit auch wirklich gar
keine luft dran kommt und die
arbeitsplatte die müsste jetzt schön
sauber machen eine lag jetzt drauf die
blüten beste musik im kühlschrank einen
tag und das ist auch ganz wichtig damit
eben dieses cmc mit dem zucker und so
weiter arbeiten kann und am nächsten tag
könnt ihr die basta aus dem kühlschrank
rausholen last auf zimmertemperatur
kommen und dann könnte sie weiter
verarbeiten
jetzt sage ich euch noch ein paar worte
zur weiterverarbeitung und zwar müsst
ihr eure hände gut einfetten mit panini
mit diesem kokosfett damit die blüten
passte nicht in euren händen klebt und
es gilt auch für die arbeitsfläche und
am besten auch für das werkzeug dass ihr
benutzt
und aus dieser blüten passte könnt ihr
jetzt blüten herstellen oder buchstaben
zahlen und ganz dünne filigrane
einzelteile die blüten passt ist nämlich
viel elastischer als pendant zum
überziehen von torten verwendet ihr am
besten wandernd und falls ihr figuren
herstellen wollte und die etwas größer
werden stellt er am besten
modelliermasse her
das geht jetzt auch zwei verschiedene
arten entweder nehmt ihr euch etwas von
land und knetet da etwas von diesen 10 c
oder ihr vermischt kontert und blüten
passte im verhältnis eins zu eins also
vom eingetragen dort kam und vom anderen
200 gramm und das begünstigt einfach
dass die figuren im hart werden und sich
nicht mehr verbiegen außerdem trocknet
die masse auch viel schneller und ihr
könnt die figur und dann besser
verarbeiten ihr könnt natürlich auch
figuren aus reiner blüten passte
herstellen
aber da ist auch die verarbeitung etwas
schwieriger weil
durch dieses zehn blüten passt ziemlich
schnell fest wird und benutzte einfach
am besten eine mischung aus blüten passt
und wandern oder eben aus sondern und 10
ich hoffe das rezept gefällt euch und
ihr problems mal aus im nächsten video
zeige ich euch dann wie ich figuren aus
modelliermasse hersteller und dann
wünsche ich euch viel spaß und viel
erfolg dabei um bis zum nächsten mal